.
>> Laura: YOU ALL KNOW PETA,
THEIR VERY NAME IS PRO-ANIMAL,
RIGHT?
THEN WHY IN THE WORLD WITH PETA
OBJECT TO A PROCEEDS AL TO MAKE
THE SWEET, CUDDLY, LOVABLE
LABRADOR RETRIEVER THE MASCOT OF
OHIO?
WE'RE DELIGHTED SHE'S WITH US,
ASHLEY.
AGAIN, FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
WATCHING, THEY DON'T KIND OF
FOLLOW THE CONTROVERSY OF
SHELTER DOGS VERSUS DOGS THAT
ARE BRED.
THEY WANT TO HAVE THE DOG AS THE
OFFICIAL DOG.
OTHER STATES HAVE OFFICIAL DOGS.
WHICH WAS NEW TO ME UNTIL TODAY.
WE HAVE DOGS THAT ARE THE
CATAHULA DOG, ALASKA, THE
MALAMUTE, THE CHINOOK, AND I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A HELICOPTER,
AND THE GREAT DANE.
WHY ARE YOU GUYS AT PETA UPSET
THAT THE LAB IS GOING TO BE
OHIO'S OFFICIAL DOG?
>> WELL, DON'T GET ME WRONG, WE
LOVE ALL DOCKS
LOVE ALL DOCK
LOVE ALL DOGS
LOVE ALL DOGS,
LOVE ALL DOGS, A
LOVE ALL DOGS, AND
LOVE ALL DOGS, AND W
LOVE ALL DOGS, AND WE
LOVE ALL DOGS, AND WE L
LOVE ALL DOGS, AND WE LOV
LOVE ALL DOGS, AND WE LOVE
LOVE ALL DOGS, AND WE LOVE I
LOVE ALL DOGS, AND WE LOVE IT
WHEN PEOPLE RECOGNIZE HOW
WONDERFUL DOGS ARE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT WHEN YOU DO
SOMETHING TO PROMOTE A SPECIFIC
DOG BREED, WHAT WE SEE IS, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE RUNNING OUT AND
BUYING LOTS OF THOSE DOGS, AND
THAT MEANS LOTS OF THOSE DOGS
EVENTUALLY ENDING UP IN SHELTERS
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN PURCHASED ON
A WHIM, AND ALSO, LOTS OF DOGS
BEING BRED BY PUPPY MILLS WHERE
THEY'RE KEPT IN DEPLORABLE
CONDITIONS.
IT ALSO MEANS LESS DOGS, LESS
MUTS BEING ADOPTED FROM
SHELTERS.
CONSIDER THE FACT THAT --
>> Laura: SO YOU'RE WORRIED THAT
BECAUSE OHIO WILL NAME THE LAB,
AS ITS OFFICIAL DOG, THAT ALL
THESE RANDOM OHIOANS WHO HAVE
NEVER HEARD OF A LAB BEFORE WILL
SUDDENLY -- I GET YOUR POINT.
I WANT TO POINT THIS OUT.
I HAD TWO LABS, BELOVED DOGS,
TROY WHO WAS 13, AND ALSO LUCY
WHO LIVED TO AGE 6.
THERE'S LUCY.
GOD REST HER SOUL.
I BELIEVE DOGS GO TO HEAVEN.
I BELIEVE THAT.
THAT'S LUCY.
BUT NOW --
>> SO DO WE.
>> Laura: ASHLEY, I NOW HAVE TWO
RESCUE DOGS.
ONE WE'RE GOING TO SHOW NOW,
JIMMY THE JUNKYARD DOG.
WE'VE GOT TO PUT JIMMY UP.
HE LOOKS VERY GUILTY.
SO I AGREE WITH YOU.
I LOVE RESCUE DOGS.
AND I SUPPORT RESCUE DOGS, I
SUPPORT SHELTERS.
BUT I THINK THIS IS WHERE PETA
LOSES PEOPLE.
PEOPLE ALREADY KNOW THE LAB IS
THE MOST POPULAR DOG IN THE